gang the state trashy tour is coming to
a city near you stand up comedy plus
we've played the Leo IG with the crowd
shows are selling out and you can get
your tickets at rugarbage.com see you
there
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage it's a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find it at the Earth to be classy
or just a big old piece of trash I'm
your little State trolley coming at you
on a beautiful day we're out back here
at titties in the new edition just saw
her walking around upstairs with a pair
of Juicy shorts on okay you seen that
thing lately yeah I don't know what
she's doing girl's got a dumper I wish
you fourth cousin I don't know God damn
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table this is a family episode just
a bozos just the homies and the boys
hippie Kevin James Ryan everybody what
up gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate if you
subscribe on iTunes please full video
available on YouTube as you know those
numbers are
and obviously the greatest website of
all time baby you said it once and said
it a thousand times
www.patreon.com are you garbage next to
the second best website of all time
www.ru garbage.com go over there and get
all your tickets for the stay trashy
tour gang and tickets are moving some
techies some teas some Zippo style
lighters uh-huh not bad there
t-shirt style t-shirts some t-shirt
style clothes
can't legally call them clothes we call
them Fabrics how about a nice quick
shout out to our producer X Jordan Air
good pal the Magic Man give it up for
Toby T-Bone McMullen what up boys what's
up pal you know what merch we gotta get
into what's that pre-cut off sleeves and
pre-cut off shorts I think we got a big
market for that but see that's that's
poser [__] as a as a as a grungy guy
yourself that's poser stuff pre-cut
they're doing the work for you yeah
we're hooking you up with the vibe
that's how you knew it was a fresh pair
of cut-offs because it wasn't frayed it
took a long summer I hated that what
you're rolling around looking like oh
dude march to may look like a real Bozo
yeah you look like a little British game
but they were worth it come August
I loved it I never had the heart though
to let them [__] Fray on their own I
would be there with tweezers or
something [__] pull pull fraying on
myself I did do that in Sea Isles never
liked that stuff and I also wasn't a big
fan of the uh the the fade in them when
you get them pre-fated or whatever what
are they called yeah you like to wear
out your own ass in a pair of pants huh
did a job myself hey let me stink these
up on my own
I don't need someone appreciating in my
pants man these jeans I got on now my
biggest fear in life right now is that
someone somehow they're gonna end up in
a washing machine because if they do the
party is over yeah you've really been
wearing those things and those things
are wide around the ankles I thought
they were sweatpants when you first came
in those things gotta bounce to them big
guy I'm debating uh I'm debating them
getting them tailored at the at the
ankle so they can so they can be a
little more skinny jeans but I'm not
going back to those uh
um I'm not going back to those joggers
those fat guy joggers I think I think
I'm I'm doing my best saving those for
when you can jog no I don't want to go
back sure because I'm over this I'm over
the belly you lift it up I didn't want
to say nut and you lifted up your shirt
pre-show that is you got a lot crammed
in that waistband well here's the yeah
man that thing is but this is this does
the job the other one it Puffs out even
more
look like Fatty Arbuckle walking around
so I'm really trying to to to maintain
and keep this going down so I don't got
to go back to the uh
to the elastic to the joggers yeah yeah
you're gonna you're in a nice set of
dungarees you're like a goddamn Cowboy
out here in your Wranglers well Brandy
you're knocking around with these are uh
True Religion jeans
is that right that's not right yes it is
that is a pair of jeans they are all
your faith is in the button
in the name of the Father the Son and
the Holy denim let's go
forgive me Father for I have sinned
they are they're True Religion those
aren't yes they origin have the pockets
the Horseshoe Pockets right horseshoe
Pockets they're not True Religions I'm
telling you okay okay we'll check it
afterwards get a Google
I need a team of guys on how big True
Religion gets you can tell True Religion
by the pockets I believe what are those
8230s
you got one number right but I'm not
going to tell you which one
you just start yelling out zip codes and
that's work somehow these are probably
46 30s I would say maybe 52s I'd have to
50 Deuce yikes
your pants or rectangles man
you're rocking 50 Deuce I got them at
the DXL a few summers ago
um and they didn't fit me all last year
but they I squeezed into them when we
went to the uh the Fourth of July uh
Premiere there's a movie yeah and Joe
lit Mr Joe list fantastic film if you
haven't seen it but you know that's a
that's a who's who Affair so I squeeze
my little ass into a [__] pair of
jeans I was dying
squeeze that little ass into a chair too
dude I was oh yeah that's right remember
I made my wife sit next to you
she's smaller framed I'm also a big guy
um but yeah and that was it that was
because that was I was I was starting to
creep a little bit so I wasn't I I never
went back to them after that I just hung
them up and then I pulled them out a
couple of weeks ago as you know and have
not stopped wearing them because they
they it's a real fat guy thing as I know
you I mean I wear the same pair of pants
every day until they until they
literally dissolve I wear like h m or
Gap jeans until they dissolve it's funny
there is a fat guy Sixth Sense where I
know that I'll fit into something that I
haven't fit into in a long time sure I
for summary you wake up in the morning
something feels different a t-shirt
catches your eye yeah I can get in there
I bet I could get in two three Puffs out
I'm in there
one of those get breakfast yep he can
get it I know it very well weird that
that's not I'm not [__] around I'm
down two three pounds this shirt never
fi you haven't seen this shirt in quite
a while okay this came back because you
typically with some [__] that's I'm
like a goddamn Kegerator yeah it's like
a motherly Instinct you just kind of
know I saw it folded in the polygon let
me give her a [__] yeah let me get to
the bottom of that drawer see what's
happening down there it smells like
mothballs and [__] see if she'll dance
with me one more time yeah I know just
put your hand down there is what do you
got in the True Religion nothing in that
size so you're full of [__] it's trying
to True Religion DXL see if they even
sell that there that's a that's probably
a better thing that could be a custom
mod you know what I mean it could be
aftermarket I got a prototype pair
and wonder why those drones have been
following me around
oh buddy I think he's got a tracking
device they got him yeah
true nation no no no that's my brand
that's my brand oh no I'm sorry you know
what these are luckies they're Lucky
jeans they're lucky they've closed
okay
true nation is my brand over there
they're great true religion is like the
that's like Affliction t-shirt that's I
knew you weren't wearing True Religions
it's lucky I apologize
okay that I might give you see do they
sell Lucky jeans at DXL yeah they so
lucky so hey watch that poof Dude that
[__] we're about to marry someone in
Vegas what are you doing hang on there
baby yeah dude that's got to come down a
little bit something you got to check
the specs on that there you go a little
more huh yeah okay yeah they sure do
about to die on a toilet there you go
all right so you got a pair of Luckys I
got a pair of what's a pair of Luckys a
DXL size 5230. these weren't cheap let
me tell you something DXL they ain't
doing any favors over there those guys
are moving reams of fabric dude
come on
I never never try on [__] pants at a
place no it's too hot I I there has to
be specific moments where I'm backed
into a corner and I got like a wedding
and for me to walk into that booth it
takes a lot and then I'll knock out a
couple of things but I go in in shorts
and I go in in a pair of Crocs I want to
be in and out and let them know you got
some money huh
I'm not just I'm not just window
shopping I came to play I need to wear
these out
ah yeah okay what's the set of luckies
go for over there 60 70 these might have
been 110 to be honest with you 115. 115
89. I'm telling you I've got my money's
worth out of these things get that to
get that down to a dollar aware baby
it's price per wear when you're
investing in a garment but I'll tell you
what they make a fine product because it
just the the the crotch hasn't given out
yet okay probably it's reinforcements
dude it's [__] you got mesh [__] you
got chainmail in that thing I gotta pay
maintenance fees they come in
dig weld it
thanks shark proof you should be wearing
them in the ocean I'm not sure
a bite resistant I can't say bite proof
but it's bite resistant
yeah that's good you're looking good
you're walking around your two little
pressed hands in the back [__] yeah
it's tight though after a couple hours
of sitting down man I really have a mark
there that looks real strange yeah looks
like I was skydiving or something like
that got into a car accident seat belt
got me yeah it's bad news that's good
though yeah things are trending in the
positive in the in the right direction
sure sure things are trained in a
positive direction
um I had to I saw this the other day
somebody wrote something out to me
um do you know anybody or did anybody in
your family I could see maybe the piece
doing this real classy move you cross
your sevens at all oh I tried it once
you can't do it what I did try it at
some point I remember being like I'm
gonna be the I think I even put a little
hat on them too you know what I mean
like the little hat like I think it was
a thing going down I think I think I had
a drop down and a t that's nice
writing in Old English saying tomato
I think I did do it at some point maybe
they taught or something but I'm not
that's a classy thing yeah real classic
I don't know what the point of it is
though it's like script like say like
you know it's like an old font people
used to write in scripts but what do you
what do you do what do you think what do
you think people think it's an L I don't
understand
it looks like a backward F you know you
know anything about that to
differentiate between the number seven
and the number one
because people would do the old school
one you have the little top on it oh I
guess if you had a top on the one you
gotta cross your set T-Bones topping the
ones and crosses the steps my ones are
eyes I was even too lazy when they were
doing that to do the the slice and then
the down and then put the put the the
stand on it get the [__] out of here
you're getting an eye that's it got it
it's dotting his ones over here and I
confused the [__] out of somebody the
other day at uh every day you encounter
a human at CVS because they walk away a
little Dumber I was trying to see if my
scripts are ready and um I was getting a
pair of Lucky's back there I was giving
them my phone number and I kept saying
nine one I I kept using o instead of
zero sure I'm an o man yeah yeah yeah
yeah big old yeah Big O I didn't realize
until late in the game like 20s that oh
wasn't zero
wait what do you mean on the phone what
do you mean no no I knew that but like
that there was like she's gonna say
how'd you get a hold of anybody that you
oh isn't uh nor is it casually yes it is
a replacement for zero I didn't say zero
told my twenties I'm saying yes until I
realized I'm like I never say zero it's
too many syllables it's too long he got
stuff to do six two oh oh nine nine
always nine here too hit him with a
Niner sure
the real mature
uh I got something I went to the mall
the other day yesterday looking after
them all up there and uh how many times
you get beat up huh
kids are real Hooligans these days I had
to poop at the mall it was bad this
wasn't the story Still Still what it's
still bad I figured the malls would be
nice there's nobody in there that's all
the fun they're trying to trying to get
uh business in there yeah they're not
starting in the bathrooms I'll tell you
that no uh it was it was
it was an away game for sure not good a
lot of a lot of pre-work had to be done
for me to even sit down
it was you install the seat
[__] in a urinal get the order
turned back on uh my thing is I don't
know uh
uh man this mall it was a little bit of
a fancier Mall didn't know just showed
up was a we're going to uh can you hit
us with a name the white uh White Plains
mall ah the White Plains mall or the
mall in White Plains I don't know the
name of it it's nice
it's like Louis Vuitton sure [__]
like high-end [__] I feel like that's
the only type of store people go out to
now I gotta tell you it's the most it's
the most crowded Mall it looked like a
mall in the 1990s I feel like malls are
coming back
people want to get out of the house the
air conditioning I don't plus they put
those you know they put like a Dave and
Buster's or a movie theater in there
you're drawing a crowd not I mean yeah
they got the paintball places laser tag
that's a did you if you're shooting
paintballs in a mall that's a bad sign
for them all that means I'm not saying
it's not a good time but that means the
mall isn't booming aeropostale's not
setting up shop next to the [__]
shooting range there's you know what I
mean they're there because that's all
they if they're selling hot tubs in your
Mall you're jammed up there's one at the
Plymouth Meeting Mall where you could
you it's uh like Target for a killer guy
you should be
40 bucks to drown
step right up step right in half price
waterboarding
oh it's Terry you don't mind
thumbs up all right can I take my break
it's gonna be rock hard but just ignore
it
showing up to work that first first day
of that yikes I thought I was gonna be
in the dunk tank I'll tell you this is
better than the medical experiments you
can tell them all's not doing well when
they have that [__] in the 90s they
didn't have that really because the
balls were boom listen of course things
have changed the marketplace has changed
for brick and mortar in the Suburban
areas however
that's when you know they're trying they
got to put those attractions in there
and I'll tell you this place it wasn't
you they get a guy with three BB guns
just want to give them 200 bucks a month
and they go have at it they don't
they're not checking insurance come on
down to Carl's black site
have you ever wanted to go to gitmo come
on down to the mall hey you got a new
pair of sneakers to get my fingernails
ripped out
listen it is a BB that that was my point
there we did it in Albany yes yeah now
what's to stop somebody from just
turning around and [__] opening up
with BBs those things sting I think it's
a game of trust you're playing you know
that guy has a BB gun on him too in case
somebody gets squirrely
yeah that's the malls are tough but this
one is what are you doing over there
I was sniffing around for a Cinnabon uh
no this is my beef
the food court
it was like I was in SoHo it was like
acai bowl there was no there wasn't one
fast food now the the closest thing to
like [__] sitting down and getting
after a football food court was a Shake
Shack that was slumming it [__] that it
was all like
raps and Juice ball and I'm like what
the [__] this is a ball in America baby
the problem the problem with that is
their no-name ones it's like a weird
name it was like Jerry's rash I was just
gonna say yeah it was all that [__] you
never heard of yeah I'm like what are we
doing here can you ask around like oh
we're big in the Midwest and then
probably in the midwest we're like oh
we're big and [__] yeah we're big on
two or three of them yeah it's [__]
[__] I don't like it at all you got
listen you got good old days when you I
mean a rock and roll a sparrow a Dane's
belly or Dane's Dane's Deli Baines Deli
Baines Baines
some no name Chinese spot the number one
Dynasty or whatever something Rock and
Roll Baby sure but even then rock and
roll I feel was newer there was rock and
roll then there was the Japanese spot
they're the ones that handed out the
chicken the Chinese and Japanese in my
Mall back would have the [__] tray
full of them man the best friend you
gotta have an Annie and you gotta have
some sort of ice cream spot up to you
you choose sure uh
none of that none of that and I was in
the mall we were shopping for [__]
Furniture which I [__] hated at a
mall dude there's a [__] Pier One
there's a [__] Creighton Barrel
there's all this Fancy on our house all
this fancy [__] my wife's dragging me to
where I'm going [__] just check
Facebook Marketplace for two three
things I'll be in the massage chair
um now my Saving Grace was [__] let's
hit the food court hit the food court
have a nice dump I had a [__] salad
at the mall like a goddamn communist it
[__] sucked I was Furious they can be
good though not
when you when you're picking out give me
this give me that get load up with that
uh
um that sesame dressing
yeah that's delicious can be good but
that's not when you want to have a salad
what would you have liked tubby
I'd go some ball I'm a saboro man at a
mall I love Sbarro I I've never claimed
to have a fancy palette man two huge
slices of sabar is a big [__] a big
coke you wanna hear a true story I'm
gonna tell you right now might have
already told you this what never had us
tomorrow
that was off limits to the Foley field
seven bucks a slice never
no you're nuts I loved it I feel like
all their slices have broccoli on them
too they did they were heavy thick
they're thick they were heavy in the
toppings they're all regular slices uh
no they're huge yeah yeah whacking the
broccoli size size of your head it was
fantastic I loved them I love them that
I would have one that I [__]
love that [__] and Applebee's a Friday's
a saboro breezy peasy I grew to hate
them because I could never have it I
know what we're doing next time we're at
a [__] airport their sodas always
looked really good too they had those
like old school Italian Pizzeria cups
they were all right wax cups size of
your [__] head too my brother would
stand there off to the side looking at
them people getting so watching my fat
asses yeah yeah
all right with our Rags on dirt on our
face you guys are looking through the
mall the window yeah yeah that was all
right a little split in an Orange Julius
that we didn't have that way in my Mall
shout out to Oxford Valley Mall starting
to phase him out a little bit
um or what was it like La Familia or
something was another big one La Familia
pizza oh yeah that's right Amelia which
I know my way around one of them dude
sweet as well yeah I think Neshaminy
Mall had uh La Familia in Oxford Valley
malletta [__] had the saboros still
there probably they're [__] they
signed 99-year leases I think gang this
episode is brought to you by betterhelp
figuring out your emotions and deal with
that stuff can be very very complicated
you got a couple of real Screwballs
sitting on a deck right here if you
don't know what's going on but you know
there's something going on it could make
things even worse so get over to better
help talk to a licensed therapist from
the comfort of your own home the Privacy
around home you could text you could
call it the video conference however you
want to play it baby they play It All
Night Long at better help yeah it's easy
to get started take a quick
questionnaire get match with a licensed
therapist if you need to switch
therapists you can do that at any time
no additional calls no questions ask
easy peasy lemon squeezy better help us
totally online so you can do therapy
whenever and wherever works for you let
therapy be your map with better help
visit betterhelp.com garbage today to
get 10 off your first month baby that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com garbage betterhelp.com
garbage to send the show notes click the
link okay let's talk about factor factor
factor factor talking about Factor 75
gang America's number one ready to eat
meal kit yep Summer's in full swing you
want to keep it tight you got not a lot
of time on your hands you're running
around you got to do this you got to do
that you got to meet the boys meet the
girls you got the kids factors got you
covered two minutes in the microwave and
they're ready to be on the plate and
they are fantastic yeah I'm a big fan of
these I've been a fan of them before
they were even years before they were a
sponsor I was using Factor they ship
them to your door easy peasy I throw it
on a skillet shh cook it up two three
minutes throw it in my gullet call it a
day if you're looking to level up even
more impress your family your date or
just yourself with factors Gourmet plus
options or upscale meals with premium
ingredients like truffle butter and
broccolini if you don't know what that
is Google it Fancy Pants you do a
candlelight dinner break out a couple of
factors though if you're literally never
want to cook again and even you can even
add factors breakfast items snacks and
smoothies I didn't know that head to
factormeals.com garbage50 and use code
garbage 50 to get 50 off that's code
garbage 50 at factormeels.com garbage50
to get 50 off factormeels.com garbage50
code garbage 50 do it yeah
you know the salad huh I was [__]
furious it's like who wants to you know
it's like that's that's your escape this
is [__] you can't get a can't get a
shitty meal to [__] I feel like the
glove should be off in the mall too
everybody should look the other way
there's got to be there's got to be two
tree treats there's got to be a stop at
the food court yeah I love that stuff
love hitting the nannies with you got
the kids with you or something like that
go in there on the cover of Darkness I
got him for the kids pushing them out of
the way got this dozen for the kids
hot dog
uh yeah it was [__] it was it was a
kick in the dick
so what happened in the bathroom
I mean it was just what do you want to
[__] go into detail what do you mean
it wasn't great it was [__] like a
stadium toilet there was yeah it was
bad I do not do well there was three
stalls and two of them were taken so it
was like you know it wasn't fantastic I
don't wanna I don't want to get this
isn't this is you know it's a family
show Prime Time program yeah talking
body humor we're above that
but it wasn't great
and what they what they have which I
don't think I've ever had I went to once
was a PF Chang's that was real
hoity-toity stuff for us do you ever do
a PF
I mean they were probably old you were
older I was in high school I've never
been to a PF Chang's but when I was this
was this is like less than 20 years ago
when the malls started selling the
parking lot
is when those places popped up for me
when they would when they started
putting restaurants in the parking lot
that those were every once in a while
those or as those things
we're spread out my family went
to one every time I'm not articulating
that right okay so
first place that they open up is the PF
Changs everybody went there for like a
year that got old news then they threw
in like a Bonefish Grill Bonefish no who
loves a Bonefish Grill a piece shout out
to Denise yeah we're going to Bonefish
sure she's got an order and I guarantee
she gets the same thing every single
time yeah yeah there's another one too
that not the Red Lion there's some
Steakhouse or something like that I
don't know yeah yeah those ever though
they all had their moments well we I
remember because we I you know
Applebee's was was our cup of [__]
tea and then that that seemed too fancy
there was I remember like out front they
had the one that oh and also all the
Jewish girls would go so I was like oh
this is real [__] yeah that doesn't be a
doctor or a lawyer or something to get
in the door there where bfj oh yeah they
loved it dude they were going to PF
Changs and I'm like oh [__] I'll be
over here eating hot dogs from [__]
Wawa and my Chevy aluminum if you need
me
um they would all go is great you want
to go and I'm like I I didn't know the
first thing about Chinese even as an
adult yeah I was 18. I was in [__]
high school you looking for bread on the
table
you got any parmesan cheese like it's
just like a chicken finger I'm like no
no no
why has it got seeds on it I love that
stuff I just didn't know and then they
would all gone I remember I went one
time never a Panda Express guy never
just I always wanted to just never got
to you find one of those in the mall
that line's out the [__] door yeah I
don't think they weren't really Around
Me growing at least you know we didn't I
didn't I never really saw them
but I remember the [__] the PF CH I
don't even the PF Changs had a I was
like nervous to go I've never been like
I don't know what I'm going to order
what's going on how much money is this
gonna cost me it was just one like you
know I probably had 30 bucks or
something like that you're trying to
speak Japanese
looking like an idiot and there was two
huge like horses at like the at the
beginning at the front entrance yeah it
was like a very very grand entrance you
wet yourself man dude I was like I don't
know and then they were like there's a
wait there's a 20 minute wait I'm like
I'm out that's [__] too rich for my
blood dude
they want my name
who would you go there with I only I
only ever made it to the entrance I
never made a group of your friends are
going sure and so you're tagging along I
think they were all like we're going how
old are you
I'm driving yeah 7 16. you got any cash
on you that's what I'm saying I probably
got 20 30 bucks and that's got to get me
a pack of heaters for the night and
beers later oh so I'm like I'm not sure
you're pregaming at this place more or
less you're going out to him they were
going this this was like when you first
started oh we're going like we're gonna
go out to eat before you're not just
getting food you know what I mean you're
not going to McDonald's or Wawa or like
the pizza place you get so you're gonna
go sit down with a group of friends I
don't think we ever did that yeah
neither did I didn't make it I didn't
make it past the door we do Ponderosa
but we get we would do the diner we go
to Great American Diner or whatever and
they [__] you know you get beers and
eggs we do Ponderosa and get like two
plates and then everybody would eat
until they got wives to us and threw us
out yeah no we took a couple of months
we would just do like you know sandwich
you know like you know it works high
pressure situation man splitting the
check little fat kid like you I was out
dude I didn't have the [__] Moxie for
it what'd you do I left I can't wait I
gotta go I gotta to work in the morning
and my kids call it yeah I made
something up and [__] high toddled
out of there and I'm sure I stopped at a
Wawa and ate in the parking lot on the
way home I had a baby sick I'm getting
indicted I gotta get out of here looks
good though
man RICO case it's a real big thing oh
[__] is it's two is it Tuesday already I
had a strong case of social anxiety back
then [__] heart pumping well it's
also food I didn't know I if you put me
in a Fridays you put me in a pizza place
you couldn't get fried right you know
what fried rice is I don't think I did
are you kidding me I don't think I did
oh I was [__] and you couldn't I
couldn't Google the menu I didn't know
so I'm like really Flying Blind I'm
expecting like a bat or something I
didn't know what they were gonna say
I'm an idiot
ah man I love that from jump Aloha and I
always talk about it man [__] love
that place best fried rice ever yeah we
didn't do I did [__] up one time and I
ordered um I meant to order low Main and
I ordered chow mein the one that's soupy
and it has like it has like lettuce or
cabbage in it and it's real soupy I'm
out oh my mom made me eat it too dude I
wanted to [__] die
not gonna waste my money I just wasn't
ready for it yet as a low main kid low
main fried rice loved an egg roll love
the shrimp roll a little sesame chicken
I'll do a dumpling sure yeah
but yeah I don't know I was a very uh
yeah I mean if
the being a picky eater that makes in
[__] anxiety
nope
meanwhile I'm at this [__] real
hoity-toity Rich spot should I get a mai
tai call me then
I'll just take some olives please
yeah it was a tough scene and you know
those broads all nice credit cards they
weren't worried about it they're
throwing down they're throwing down
plastic sure now
yeah I made I remember yeah I remember
pulling out of the [__] parking lot I
mean like hey calls me when these are
done or whatever what'd you do just
drive around I probably went to a Wawa
and got a [__] Hoagie it makes me
feel bad for you yeah it wasn't great
bleeding up to him I mean it wasn't that
it wasn't you got your nice Ambercrombie
shirt on nah that was probably by the
way I saw that that uh that Instagram
post I forgot to ask you about that sure
that's what I sent that to Yani that's
what you kids were rocking back then I
don't remember those shirts not that I
don't remember not wearing them it'd be
weird if you were at the party hey we
were 16 or 17.
but I don't remember that being your
guys's fashion uh unless you guys just
not not to be rude but you won't really
pull it off
I mean I could see your T-shirt right
through that thing yeah I mean what he
thought it was from Kohl's dude
um no so that all right that was
probably 16 17 call it that was when
hip-hop what year are we talking
2003. I graduated in 2005 so I was gonna
be 2003. we had something like that okay
what what did you do I was looking at
the picture
yeah it's just so funny to have three
guys all wearing the same [__] oh yeah
same hot same hats same shirts and you
see there's a fan out we're out back
we're outside and there's a there's a
there's an indoor fan outside someone
goes I can't tell if this picture is
indoors outdoors and that's a problem
laughs yeah I didn't uh no so that was
when uh that started switching from like
the jerseys and stuff like that to like
Jay-Z said like you weren't wearing that
right what the jerseys yeah you were
wearing the jerseys yeah I still have
them at my mom's I have basketball
jerseys and I had matching hats for each
one like to go out oh yeah school
picture day what do you mean really yeah
man I didn't know that uh-huh damn yeah
not cool I thought I was cool Entourage
kitty yeah it was very Turtle very
turtle-esque sure backwards fitted hat I
had like a Chris Weber Kings jersey with
the matching Sacramento Kings hat had an
Iverson jersey uh
Cleveland it would have been what right
like the camera the LeBron Jersey would
win the captain Iverson I said oh
Iverson Chris Webber Iverson Mike Bibby
I have was a big Kings fan Mike Bibby
just putting that hat on going I'll
never regret this
yeah they had this can he get laid more
than once in a night the lens of the
future will shine favorably on this
outfit
yeah so wait it started Denver Nuggets
Jersey hat it started to transition from
that to what Jay-Z told you not to wear
those anymore I called you personally I
did he goes yo Kip we ain't doing this
no more
laughs
uh yeah he raped about like no more
somebody commented in the comments of no
like this is right when JC Jay-Z said no
more jerseys I said you are not wrong my
friend
um so you went button up yeah give me a
Chris pair of jeans and a button-up and
that was that was big the button up did
he mean that though with the stripes I
don't know when I think button up he was
he also wasn't shopping at Kohl's okay I
had to do the best with what I had and
Denise was only taking me to Kohl's she
wasn't a proven cool button-ups
you never got your hands like an
Ambercrombie or anything like that that
was it that's not he didn't mean that
you know there's no m in that store
right Ambercrombie
Ambercrombie Ambercrombie and Finch well
that's not a thing Ambercrombie
Abercrombie Abercrombie yes Abercrombie
and Fitch Abercrombie and
Fincher T not an end dude oh there's no
end [__] wait hold on Abercrombie and
Fitch Abercrombie
Abercrombie is that am I saying that
right yeah Abercrombie and Fitch not
Ambercrombie and Finch Amber cranby's a
school a girl I went to school
Yo Miss creamy yeah her first name's
Amber Amber hey Miss cranby is Amber
home
Amber Granby
she went on to be a superhero a porn
star
same thing okay doing the Lord's work
either way you weren't shopping there
because for a minute but that wasn't
cool when I was banging that wasn't cool
I would Abercrombie was was nerd alert
because I would say maybe around 2003
2004 what you're talking about I came
into uh I came into a big score on a
[__] tax refund and uh I was going
out with my brother and wanted to really
wow them and uh I picked up a suit from
Banana Republic
hey what do you have in terms of bananas
here dude I met them at some bar he was
like what the [__] is that
but it was it was casual though was it
casual oh you don't say the yellow suit
you weren't going into close ass were
you
hey guys don't be intimidated by my
power suit this is casual I'm just
hanging out tonight no kind of yellow
it was yellow
it was a mustard stain yellow ah sorry
I'm late I was ringing the bell on Wall
Street
are there any question marks on this
suit
hey gang
I'm here to save you there's a bunch of
loopholes in the tax code oh [__]
no it was when I say casual I mean
um it was uh we'll take the CEO of Gray
papon
yes it was very great poupon-esque which
I loved as a kid what was under what
kind of shirt were you wearing
um tuxedo t-shirt
Iris and Jersey
my my high school football jersey I
thought it paired well what's up
um uh what's it called canvas not canvas
not canvas the [__] that they're wearing
now
linen yes it was like a linen suit where
did you go it was February that was on
the discount
yeah yellow and okay where was it I had
a white shirt where were you going just
some bar just went to meet him and his
buddies at some bar this is a lot for
ohanigan
it was downtown I thought it was nice
man I know the field not knowing and
trying to dress cool is
don't look now big bird just pulled up
to the bar
I was skinny mini back then I was
probably like [__] Buck 89. tight
looking idiot
I had [__] tan shoes no socks it's a
tan belt had the shirt tucked in yeah
how much that run you it was a lot a
couple hundred enough to send me into
uh a panic-induced anxiety session the
next day about what did I do I just
spent all the money that I just got
got a reoccurring thing back then yeah
plus there was a couple other expenses
expenses that evening
I think I went through my whole refund
check yeah you can you can't wear a
yellow suit and not do blow all night I
mean what's the [__] point it
probably came in the pockets
instead of Scarface lining to it instead
of the buttons
yeah a guy wearing a yellow suit going
out is obviously doing blow yeah
and wants everyone to know it
man it's a tough look but that neither
here nor there I was dipping in that
kind of stuff
that one time yeah Republic's always
been you know that where that's where I
could you warn them your buddies didn't
have though they weren't cold shirts
they were nicer shirts no that that was
or they just fit them a little better
they just also um mines I think the fans
blowing it so it really I look real wide
I wasn't that wide looking back I would
have took in every picture
like that oh yeah every picture I've
ever taken I would have been in the back
row like had someone like I would just
spin the hell what's up you know
throwing the Deuces up yeah I noticed
you were big on those you were big on
the Deuces big on the deuce and the
middle finger big middle finger yeah man
that never would have flown the middle
finger clone with who anybody I wasn't
doing with my mom I wasn't at
Thanksgiving like [__] [__] it was
[__] drinking with my boys dude which
middle finger would you do thumb out or
Thumb in
I was typically Thumb in Eminem was big
on the thumb out yeah that yeah I don't
give me wrong don't don't get me wrong
on Facebook I'm there's I'm I don't like
that I don't like the the other finger
popped up there yeah what are you a
priest all of a sudden shut up go put
your yellow suit on and dance monkey I
still have it uh
um yeah in case you ever scored a day
with the Chiquita banana lady
proud of well not proud of it but hey I
I I I show it and a lot of people
resonates with a lot of people of course
of course I just wasn't in my head when
you talked about those shirts I didn't
expect them to wear like that I don't
know I'm telling maybe maybe it was the
flash it was the bad angle it's a bad
I'm like putting my eyes I would
stretching out I wasn't that's a that's
a bad angle I was a William and Sonoma I
remember that the shirt yeah oh that
that was not no that's in their hands
so you come here often and the [__]
just slides right off me
I'm like a drop of dawn
runs away
I'm sure you're doing all right back
then oh God young kid like you
yeah but that's what that was that
picture is a top I mean it is what it is
I am what I am I'm a human onion people
of course how many people you know can
go from fitteds and jerseys to cool
button-ups from Kohl's yeah it is what
it is
I thought more solid colors that was
College that's when Express came out
Express came out with the solid button
and there's a lot of pics of me with
that the blue was big but this was maybe
a little bit before that this was like
right after 9 11. the Upper East Side
was [__] ripe with those royal blue
shirts sure a lot of restaurants that
was the uniform with the black pants or
whatever oh man yeah it was all right
yeah I've always been ahead of the curve
when it comes to Fashion I feel
I've always been one step ahead you know
what's classic and nice is a nice pair
of jeans and a solid blue button down
the light the normal button Downs yeah
you can't [__] that no I what I what in
a perfect world perfect 100 perfect
world I'd wear blue jeans and a white
T-shirt every day just I do not have the
body to pull that off I can't even pull
off a white T-shirt under a jacket you
know what I mean my belly you can see my
belly button
it's like a black hole yeah I spin span
why I'm all black teas and black jeans
those are my Hot Topic phase
but
my fashion choices of notwithstanding of
course yes gentlemen such as yourself
neither here nor there we have business
to get together we do it's a family
episode gang door is do a little couple
of cues here from the old patreon uh-huh
when you sign up for the patreon when
you answer your garbage question on the
Airing God do I gotta tell you got some
goddamn humdingers over here okay what
do you know about Harry's baby oh baby
I'm no longer hairy because of Harry's
that's pretty good
gang Harry's you get high quality razors
you got a luxury experience at not
luxury prices we're talking about face
wash grooming stuff keep you smelling
and looking good thanks to Harry's yeah
it's fantastic I I use it on on the
bottom of my neck there to clean up the
line down here to define a chin because
I don't have one and then everything
else used to be the bumps Harry's don't
give me the bumps though got a lot of
good stuff over there uh their starter
clip their starter kit includes five uh
includes a five blade German engineered
razor with a lightweight handle foaming
shave gel and a travel cover to keep
things sanitary you can even schedule
delivery for refills for as low as two
dollars look at that with the highest
customer service satisfaction in the
Shaving industry you truly can't go
wrong if you're not completely satisfied
Harry's even offers a no risk trial so
you can so so shave so your shave is on
them go to uh to get your best shave
ever this summer go to Harry with
Harry's razors and skin care products
there you go a 13 starter set for just
three dollars at aries.com garbage
that's harrys.com garbage for a three
dollar Starter Set baby you're in there
for the price of nothing
um harrys.com garbage do it
I see what you got fatty uh this one is
a spin on something we've talked about
before this is from Roy are you garbage
if you don't realize you're out of bread
so you send your kid to school with a PB
and J tortilla
that's never happened there was never
tortillas in the house well we were
talking about a banana dog yes which is
a hot dog or a banana on a hot dog roll
yeah
yeah but I gotta be honest with you I
love tortillas and I love PB and J the
PB J and T I didn't I thought I invented
that at a certain point because that
didn't start until I was much older when
I was like what the [__] am I doing
[__] put this on a tortilla however
what I didn't know I mean I never mine
never came what that never came from
like I can do this it's more of I have
to do this because I'm out of [__]
job
of course of course making some North
Shore quesadillas yeah what's North
Shore quesadilla it's a fun name for
peanut butter jelly tortilla that's not
bad it's actually pretty good patent
pendant you know what I didn't realize
until much much much later in life and I
ruined most of my tortilla experience by
this I didn't know to [__] heat it up
on the stove on the open stove that's
only that's only very recent for
everybody man everybody gives you that
note Game Changer I used to see the guys
when I worked at the Greek place down in
the West Village that's how they would
heat up the pita oh Peter's the same way
oh yeah yeah so we're non that's all
that's all got to be done Open Flame
yeah yeah Open Flame throw it in the
salamander on air big fan of that so
that you cool it down a little bit you
do you do a little peanut butter you do
a little jelly and you make it like a
quesadilla maybe put your chips or some
pretzels on there get a little crunch to
it that was all right but not in school
just patty just never
they weren't they never really hung out
around the house either if they did they
were left over from taco night or
whatever and we never did that we were
hard taco shell we were the Ortegas same
with us they only came in probably when
I was in junior high or high school
they're every six months there might be
a bag sitting there of like some like
car balance one that Denise was trying
you ever try to make those work with
something like everything like when okay
so you have taco night you do the
Ortegas she puts maybe half of the shell
there's always shells left over sure man
trying to make one I just could never
figure out the science behind it I'm
like it looks like a Dorito it kind of
tastes like a Dorito why can't I make
this work the hard shell taco is no good
dude because when you're going to bite
at a certain point you hit that
midsection where now you gotta bite from
the top and you're only getting tomatoes
and lettuce and then the the meat sogs
is up the bottom it's not that you have
to put them in the oven they're a little
every time they be Bland or something
I've tried this two times I can't figure
it out
I'm on the you know Ritz crackles and
cheese whiz or whatever yeah my mom used
to send my brother to school with a
pretty trashy lunch she'd do instant
Ramen like Maruchan ramen noodles in a
thermos is that how you pronounce that
Maruchan I never even attempted sounds
like a bail bondsman maroon [__]
yeah but you better pay because I'll put
you back in I don't know if that's it ah
probably not those things are all right
though y'all they're great but she'd put
them in a thermos with the hot water and
the powder in the morning and it would
just sit oh sogging up in that thermos
my brother loved that [__] I mean I do
like I would imagine the noodles would
get over could get mushy yeah it'd be
pure mush Ah that's how I like my nudes
sending you to [__] school with soup
cheap soup at that not even like not
even hey here's a bisque that's
guaranteed and it's a prison meal that's
what like bricklayers do
that's bad never soup never
soup I would [__] lose it
that would be her last day on the job I
tag it off that bus I'm looking to chew
somebody's ass out I could see a soup if
it was paired with a grilled cheese
you get the soup at the school they'll
do a soup in the winter whip you
something up they'll throw you a tomato
soup that's wild poor bastard and he
liked it loved it really
huh
what was the accoutrement what was it
what was the dessert on that [__]
wedgie yeah
I always came on with his hair wet
couldn't figure it out Ketch of gold uh
uh this one's from uh Kip and Hank's
garage Adventure shout out to you ten
dollar homie never have one red is it
garbage if you give all your kids names
that start with the same letter for
example my mom has won a seven named
Darlene Denise Diane Debbie Donald
Dennis and Danny that's a crew yeah
Darlene Dennis Diane Debbie Donald
Dennis and Danny yeah there's something
there's something to that
that's yeah that ain't classy no you got
Deb you got done you got Den you got Dan
you got you got nisi and you got Dar
yeah
that's what dog if there was a Darlene
in my family she would be dar
th there's Amara she's Amar but your mom
dear parents your grandparents didn't do
that right what they didn't name
everybody no that's the question oh okay
I thought you just named you said Denise
no but they had there's a Denise in
there oh okay yeah she's not the only
one am I what yeah Denise yeah the piece
isn't the only Denise floating around
she should be though her nickname's
Niecy Niecy Niecy growing up her that
was just it so we abbreviate every name
Brett Brendan goes to Brandon Bridgette
goes to Bridge I think the short answer
is yes that's true yeah but that's a
that's a wrecking crew dude yeah but I
like it you gotta die die Deb Don den
and Danny come rolling through they are
there to [__] [__] up
just a two of them yeah see like that
for some reason that's comforting to me
I bet you they all have a dish that's
[__] awesome it's like the with um
the big big uh yeah yeah I bet it's yeah
it's [__] it's trashy but it's
[__] all right man
Little slice of America they all if it's
anything like my family too they all
come with rules like
they're certain they they don't touch
his ears no but like you know they all
have their own it's very at this point
everybody now knows everybody's no [__]
Deb don't like it when you make fun of
her feet don't make fun of Deb's feet
yeah Bridge don't like it when you curse
no they're you know Uncle Dan has this
very specific way he likes his coffee
and everybody all 50 of us know it yeah
with some rumplements in it I feel like
he would uh he would bring a six-pack of
his own beer and you weren't allowed to
drink whatever he drank that Uncle oh
this guy yeah yeah you know what I mean
sure he's the only one that drinks Bush
light or something like that he loves
them and they can't drink them you know
what I you know what I I I've realized
I'm getting to the point too because you
know growing up right when I started to
be allowed to drink at Family parties
it's so funny I wanted to talk about
this when I started to be a lot of drink
at Family parties it was yeah I was late
High School like most people really
depends on the party and the company at
the party We snuck it if it's my uncle's
and made it better we're out doing
something wrong what
[__] I don't want information I'm
trying to feel something well I was the
youngest of all my uncles and all my
cousins and my uncles so they were all
like my brother and sisters they said
they were all drinking so they were like
yeah [__] you can drink and then like
the uncle started being like yeah is
Kevin get the button-down shirt on
but I've been listening to Jay-Z what
more do you want from me uh
but I remember would be like what are
you drinking right we're making the
plans for let's say Thanksgiving oh yeah
and I was always the whatever I don't
I'm like what do you drinking [__]
whatever you got
oh okay I like I'm like [__] whatever
and they're like I remember being like
Uncle Pat only Drake get Uncle Pat's
drinking yinglings oh yeah of course
that or the big thing is they were on
something that year or two you know like
he's not drinking Coors Lights no more
he's drinking he's off to yinglings he's
getting too fat he's on the light
because everyone sees real high he
switched over to Heineken Light he's off
the ipas he's on a he's on the cores
again or whatever and now I'm doing that
it's because like now I'm getting calls
from like my brother-in-law for like
going to dinner or like going to have
like pizza night or whatever with the
kids what are you drinking Woody and I'm
like I'm doing a Coors Lights or I'm
doing Twisted Tea lights yeah
it's very I'm like oh [__] I've become
that fat uncle
I become the uncle whose weights
fluctuating and things what are you
drinking it's gonna change it and not
the 15 slices of zom about to have six
Emulsion for the kid triple x
uh all right let's see this one's Tommy
G 10 bozo is it garbage to repeaters by
the kitchen vent thinking that'll take
the smell out
buddy been there one two three million
times and I feel like it does help a
little bit oh it doesn't I just out of
the movement can I ask you this about
those uh-huh when I was a kid I was
under the impression that they went
somewhere
commercially they do in my mind I'm dude
it's just a fan the ones in your
kitchens typically are just a fan they
don't there's not a pipe or that goes
and then goes out of the building
probably not in your house no it's the
exhaust is right on top the exhausts and
then just blows it out it's just a fan
yeah unless I mean I doubt most
residential I couldn't figure out how to
save my [__] life when you when you
do have one that just takes it
just [__] right up and out daddy out
you're rippity oh wait yeah well I would
light it off the stove
and then just flick the vent on and and
also smoke it in the kitchen there's
less fabric
so there's less smell true that was
always my Dirtbag logic in any house
okay can we smoke in here not yet wait
till around midnight then the ciggies
they don't happen in the living room you
got to be a goddamn animal to just crank
cigs in the living room sitting on the
couch you smoke them in the kitchen yeah
you got the you got a window open you
got the vent going you got the fan going
and there's nothing for us to stick to
uh-huh there's science behind my Dirtbag
logic sure and it worked man I remember
my dad just ripping heater laying down
sideways with his hand in his head
watching something on TV that's so not
comfortable to me I dude he would fall
asleep like crazy right that was already
my dad the same way be [__] reading
the paper cranking [__] on the couch
and I'm like that's not that's not how I
like my stuff this was the floor he was
on the floor playing
sideways like that yeah that's so wild
to me nuts you know what pairs really
well with a cigarette on a couch being
hammered drunk oh that'll be
go into the refrigerator but also my
first apartment up here we would crank
[__] I mean that was that was a full
smoking apartment never like everyone in
it just smoke you would be by the window
you'd have to open the window
and you would be by the window typically
that gives me anxiety in the sense of
there was a lot of that waiting for
someone to show up and that's yeah in my
past experience sweating that triggers
that February I'm waiting you're waiting
for the guy to come yeah yeah
thinking about the heater after the guy
after the shore you know once everything
straightened out yeah once you get your
head on straight that's going to be
great then and you're like kind of like
anticipatingly chasing that
beforehand pregaming it yeah I don't
like that yeah it gives me anxiety I had
Vibes bought a Sig inside ain't bad I I
you know I don't love them
it depends on the setting
but six and sides are just cooler at
times why don't condone smoking of
course
um they always made it look good in
movies like when like when they be I
always think to myself like are they
wreaking they got to be reeking they
gotta smell
you know I was watching Sex In The City
the other day it was on
I feel like it doesn't stick to like
somebody like Sarah Jessica Parker
doesn't stick to them the same way it
sticks to now our fat ass is coming in
from outside it does it's just that
everybody was smoking so nobody could
smell it but she's got the perfume and
she's that almost smelled good you know
what I mean back in the day a little bit
of smoke mixed in with with the perfume
I never liked the lady that smoked as a
smoker really yeah I'm a [__] Dirtbag
I love that you know what I mean
um but she rolled over right after sex
in bed which I'm like that ain't
happening anymore is it I don't think it
ever did I think that was all like that
was all just that was all Edward Bernay
[__] I've done that have you of course
is sleeping in a refrigerator box but
yeah uh I've never done it in bed it was
in the I had it after it was in the
apartment where my bed was in my closet
so all of my clothes were directly above
me just getting roasted dude
your life was like a sleepover Junior
High you should have been telling your
Burt Reynolds
oh no yeah I smoke in my house he
immediately started arguing with the
girl
about like college money and [__] like
that watch me burn myself I don't feel
it at all
psycho uh yeah that that but they did
that and I was like are people they're
probably not people still just rolling
over cranking heaters in bed because
that'll stick we just didn't think it
stuck and everything everybody did smell
like smoke back in the day in bed
smoking in bed wild yeah you got fitted
sheets of burn holes in them there's a
lot I guarantee you someone's watching
this show or listening to this show in
bed with a burn ripping a heater ripping
a steak I got two three raincoats or
fall jackets that have [__] that that
have burning holes right by on the thing
little Brisco wind hit you sure stop
thinking about it I got a jacket that I
would use to just go out and catch
heaters that that right sleeve is just
[__] smells like it was in a bonfire
just from you know what I mean it's
always raining or whatever and it makes
it stick even more
it's like you open the closet and you're
like what the [__] he's catching a raw
heater in here
uh all right let's see here uh
uh this right in the same vein this
one's from Travis is it garbage to
propose to your girlfriend in your
Bernie's t-shirt
shout out to you shout out to you that's
a that's a marriage that'll last forever
we made to save the date
we did make someone save the date yeah
they hit us up we're on their website
you like log in and it's the it's uh
shout out to the happy couple yeah you
go to like reserve or RSVP and we're
we're on it
who the [__] are these guys oh these fat
idiots
I love it uh all right this one's from
spaghetti bad guy have you ever just dug
a hole
yeah I have that's a good time for no
reason at all I'ma Dig Me Oh the best is
when you just catch a rock and that
becomes the project oh I Excavating you
you feel like you're a [__] you know
I feel like you're an archaeologist
what is it yeah I remember doing it in
the backyard as a kid just digging a
hole just [__]
those summer days it seemed like you're
home alone and we said it a thousand
times but a day seemed like a month
you'll check the clock it was 12 15
you're like No One's Gonna be home for
another [__] five and a half hours
start digging up the bumps call before
you dig check the pipes on this thing
um yeah I love digging a hole Yeah uh uh
all right let's see this one's from
Deborah hey I'm new how about this are
you garbage if your former mother-in-law
actually slept with Evil Knievel back in
Montana whoa your former mother-in-law
slept with Evil Knievel shout out to her
that's I mean that's like an American
Legend one of many my friends
I hate to tell you that one of many yeah
Knievel did all right was he married
Evil Knievel I believe he was
I believe he was sure yeah it was
different that's risk in his life he's
jumping a goddamn green candy let him
get a little side in a regular [__]
bike it was none of that [__] that they
have now we're talking heavy but this
guy was just [__] doing it uh-huh no
real
skill for lack of a better word just a
[__] set of cojones
with local ladies man he was evil he was
married
couple times I think
and he also was in a semi-pro hockey
player what yeah the Butte bombers dude
what a name they don't have names like
that anymore the Butte bombers there's
some connection with that is there a
connection to Kurt Russell and him no he
the Kurt Russell had the the bastards or
whatever the that was a that was a
baseball team okay yeah yeah in Spokane
or Portland or something I thought it
was in Montana the bastard's a baseball
they ripped off the Czechoslovakian
Olympic ice team
how they uh to promote the team and earn
money he convinced the Olympic team from
Czechoslovakia to play an exhibition
game against the Butte bombers It's the
Most Daring feat yet Knievel got ejected
in the third period [__] for running
over a guy with his motorcycle
with the check on Slovakian team went to
settle up for the night all the receipts
have been stolen
America you need receipts here all they
heard was the sound of a Harley tearing
off into the night
man he was he was [__]
the best even more so than like my other
like toys or whatever because Fisher
Price came out with uh they had a
motorcycle guy which was basically him
but without the
um without the marketing The Branding
he has like the stripes and [__] like
that
this guy was [__] awesome and once he
loosened up a little bit you could
really [__] do some fun [__] with him
I missed him completely he was wait when
was his last jump Toto yeah this was
probably before we were born he in my
head he was already like a lot not a
wife but already like a lure yeah you
were born what 86 86. I mean you
probably jumped in the early 90s I think
I vaguely remember that but when he was
hot was the 80s yeah and that was all I
mean I missed it completely he was like
yeah he was like a guy you just heard
people talk about Super Dave Osborne
took over God I'll tell you man Marty
Funkhouser the Snake River Canyon
1974. that was his last jump get the
[__] out of here no it couldn't have
been alive Knievel made his most daring
and final jumps at Twin Falls across the
Snake River Canyon really earning the
Guinness book of world record for most
broken bones in a lifetime Nancy he was
already did it
he was just Legend when I was my insides
are powder yeah holy [__] yeah so his
last jump was seven yes I mean
you know I've in the mid 90s I'm seven
or whatever his kid took over his kid
saw to jump was there an Evil Knievel
Junior yeah I vaguely remember that
Ronnie Knievel Ronnie
Ronnie yeah he did
not like evil I'm telling you man he was
good
maybe it's Ronnie needs to jump buses I
think I remember jump to buses I think
he jumped something in Vegas that
documentary's old Robbie Robbie Knievel
yeah Ronnie Ronnie can't even change the
oil in a [__] motorcycle I passed
away yeah he's not that long ago right
uh yeah 2023 yeah
shout out to him a couple of American
Originals that's crazy that his last
jump was in 74 because I like remember
seeing them on TV maybe it was super
Dave no Ronnie was jumping into the 80s
and 90s I think was he I don't think he
was doing it back then though I think he
that didn't start until like the 90s I'm
saying that's maybe what you remember
seeing nah this feels like in the early
80s I remember like watching Evil
Knievel jump over stuff
maybe my dad had it on tape probably
yeah you have YouTube back then also for
instead of Big Buck Hunter we were gonna
get a [__] uh Evil Knievel pinball
machine but the guy wanted crazy money
that guy real real j-o movies like make
me an offer yeah T-Bone made him an
offer and he [__] I used to they
[__] didn't respond yeah
yeah his last jump was in 2008.
damn okay but he didn't use a heavy bike
he used uh motocross bike okay
yeah his dad was just using [__]
that's all he had been regular
motorcycles no Kawasaki oh he was just
grabbing something from the valet just
crashing it's got gas in it man imagine
that you break all those bones six
months a year to recover you [__]
back out there and do it again
I mean those paychecks are probably all
right probably you know what I mean and
he got a bit of a death wish or you
don't care if you die so you're [__]
hey let's [__]
do a couple Eagle swords you know sure
jump the goddamn Grand Canyon sure
um all right let's see this one's from
Jen we kind of talked about this before
ten dollar ten dollar homie uh is it
garbage to stop by a little league
concession stand for some snacks if you
don't know anyone playing on the field
that's are you there watching the game
are you just cruising back just stop by
lights are on at the stadium means that
Grill's on too let's play ball you're
supporting the kids you're supporting
the township or the league the local
thing what are you doing there though
they're not like on the street
yeah they're like in they're you gotta
Park and then like get to yeah you gotta
walk through the woods a little bit if
it's a crowded you know if it's a game
the parking lot's crap that's yeah your
buddy you're better off just [__]
call an Uber Eats or stopping at a
[__] Wawa or something they don't get
those walking around tacos I'll tell you
that man I love a [__] snack bar
God damn amen sister
yeah that's trash why do you [__] I
would eat at a snack bar growing up
probably three times a week between my
games my brothers games are my sister's
games you just say I'm dropping you off
at the field whatever between you know
ever we played multiple Sports you're
just [__] man if that thing closed
that was a sad day I [__] what am I
supposed to do it's not even open over
here starving they're running out of
pretzels yeah
it's halftime we've got to go to my
cousin cousin Joe's basketball games uh
when he played for King's College in
Wilkes-Barre we'd go there and that I'd
be waiting for halftime [__] bolt up
to the snack bar they had everything
yeah cool
big fan couple of diesels too a couple
of these on a Wednesday at like 7 30.
just been sitting in a roller for
[__] four days after dinner we're
talking after dinner diesels
adds plus I got money in the game
got my cousin my cousin's gonna play
bull he's gonna throw it in the third
uh all right let's see here we can do
one more and then we gotta get up out of
her
um this one's from Jim 20 homie shut up
hey twenty dollar board member um is a
garbage only shave with shampoo
which I've done shave with shampoo I
always went conditioner because it felt
thicker a little yeah a little a little
more consistent well hold on there is
something to that
to use conditioner when you're shaving
with a razor if you put conditioner on
your face
it softens the hair
it does there is a little something to
that there is give you some Wicked acne
though I'll tell you that yeah I can
feel it I can feel the hair ripping out
of my face I [__] but the shampoo
gives you a little bit more sudsy it's
only the shampoo gets a little more
frothy yeah I was soap we would use soap
that's the first thing I've done it with
[__] like just bar soap in a hotel
when you've been real jammed up I did it
before a wedding one time I forget where
I was
and man it's a bad reaction to it or
something was like dude look I had a red
beard at the [__] wedding it was a
[__] tough look I hope I never have
to shave with a razor like that ever
again well I've just made that decision
that I'm just never doing that every
time I use a regular razor it looks like
I lost a fight to a raccoon I hate it
I'm just bleeding the way that feels
trim it trim it keep it low and slow
like yeah you can break the beard
trimmer it's [__] on the lowest thing
cool I'm out the door I don't care
anymore I'm not trying to impress no
goddamn body I'm not trying to get into
PF Chang those those Norms have relaxed
I think a little bit too sure yeah we
were kids every day they got your dad
shaved yeah you had every single morning
shaved that had to suck I mean I
remember even like you know a few years
I was shaving two times a week two three
like I would let it get like a little
scruff and I was like all right I was
[__] Baby Face McGee over here
[__] getting carded and stuff
baby's got a receding Airline oh bless
your heart all right we gotta wrap it up
gang gang I'm gonna tell you this we
love you to death see you next week
peace